bon
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24 heures sénat et on commence tout de
suite par l'hommage du sénat à nelson
mandela l'ancien président sud africain
décédé vendredi à l'âge de 95 ans à
l'ouverture de la séance jean pierre bel
a salué un homme engagé un
révolutionnaire un sage en l'écoutent
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
à quelques moments de l'histoire au fil
des siècles
s'élèvent des femmes et des hommes qui
par leur courage
par leur détermination
dans une confiance et espoir à des
millions d'autres
nelson mandela était de ceux qui
incarnent les grandes luttes de leur
temps et change le cours de l'histoire
nelson mandela nous a quittés le 5
décembre
dans son combat contre le racisme contre
la justice nelson mandela a porté au
plus haut ses convictions ses valeurs
chevillée au corps la liberté l'égalité
la fin des discriminations
c'était un être rayonnant éclate en
apportant un peu de lumière dans un
vingtième siècle trop longtemps marqué
par sa part d'ombré
nelson mandela c'est d'abord le militant
engagé il participa à la création en
1944 de la ligue des jeunes du congrès
national africain la haine c'est avant
de se rapprocher du parti communiste sud
africain
nelson mandela ce fut un révolutionnaire
un homme d'action dans ce pays où gandhi
séjourne à plus de vingt ans et où il
conduisit ses premiers combats
politiques il mena des actions de
désobéissance civile contre des
centaines de lois qui retirait aux noirs
aux indiens et aux métis leurs droits et
libertés contre ce qu il dénonça comme
un système monolithique
diabolique dans le détail
inéluctable dans son objectif
écrasant dans son pouvoir
cette désobéissance lui valut ces
premières condamnations
mais dans la résistance il acquit le
sentiment de marcher droit comme nomme
et de regarder tout le monde dans les
yeux avec dignité oui
révolutionnaire et non violents il
fallut l'horreur du massacre de
sharpeville
le 21 mars 1960 pour qu'il reconsidère
les méthodes d'action de la nd c'est
face à la brutalité sanglante de
l'apartheid qui ignoré les
revendications légitimes de la
population noire il entra dans la
clandestinité
arrêté à son retour en afrique du sud
après un voyage dans une douzaine de
pays il est mis en prison le 5 août 1962
vous le savez pour n'en ressortir que le
11 février 1990 près de 28 ans après à
73 ans cet homme enfin libre incarné
alors l'avenir du pays
je me tiens devant vous non pas en tant
que prophète mais en tant que serviteur
de vous le peuple déclara-t-il en toute
humilité son nom avait été avait porté
l'espoir de ceux qui luttèrent pendant
40 ans contre l'apartheid
parvenu à faire tomber le système
ségrégationniste qui avait voulu le
briser mandela fut un sage sa force sa
grandeur d'âme lui venait aussi de la
culture de choses a découvertes au cours
de son adolescence dans la tribu thème
où il avait fait sienne l'ubuntu cette
philosophie de fraternité fondée sur
l'appartenance de chacun un ensemble
plus vaste à une humanité qui oblige ou
respect à la compréhension d'autrui
loin de tout esprit de revanche
nelson mandela conduisait son pays sur
le chemin de la réconciliation
dans le symbole universel de toute lutte
contre le racisme et contre l'oppression
ce héros au sourire si doux pour
reprendre les mots
torgau donna à ces combats un visage
prix nobel de la paix premier président
démocratiquement élu de la république
d'afrique du sud c'est à sharpeville
qu'il choisit en 1996 de parapher la
nouvelle constitution de la nation
arc-en-ciel
mandela madiba resta toute sa vie fidèle
à la plaidoirie qu'il prononça lors du
procès de rivonia il y à un demi siècle
voit vous voir sa vie à la lutte pour le
peuple africain pour l'idéal d'une
société démocratique et libre dans
laquelle tous vivraient ensemble dans
l'harmonie avec des gal opportunités
nelson mandela savait qu'il ne suffit
pas d'abolir certaines lois iniques
offert à disparaître les idées qui ont
pu conduire à leur adoption il était
conscient que tout ne vient pas en
quelques mois conscient du chemin qui
reste à parcourir pour que chacun vive
dans le respect et la dignité qui lui
sont dus
nelson mandela nous lègue ce message
cette responsabilité celle devrait
encore et toujours pour la liberté
contre les discriminations raciales pour
ses idéaux universels auxquels notre
pays est si profondément attaché le cher
collègue par vos applaudissements je
vous demande de rendre hommage à nelson
mandela
merci
voilà pour cet hommage appuyé de la
haute assemblée à nelson mandela on va
tout de suite retrouvé tomes traduits en
direct de la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle car les sénateurs et bien
débattent actuellement de l'intervention
militaire française en centrafrique un
débat oui mais pas de vote tam et oui
effectivement un débat sans vote et pour
cause puisque nous sommes cinq jours
après le début de cette intervention
militaire française à bangui en
centrafrique
un débat sans vote qui a débuté par
l'intervention du ministre de la défense
jean yves le drian jean yves le drian
qui est intervenu pour justifier cette
intervention française au centrafrique
avec trois arguments principaux d'abord
la légalité internationale il l'a bien
souligné cette intervention s'insère
dans le cadre d'une résolution de l'onu
qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité par le
conseil de sécurité
deuxième point cette intervention n'est
pas fait pour durer après les forces
françaises c'est la musque à la force
africaine qui doit venir prendre le
relais la muscat qui doit passer de 2500
à 6000 hommes et qui doit ensuite mené à
un processus électoral démocratique
et puis en cas de problème il y aura
ensuite une opération de maintien de la
paix de l'onu enfin cette opération est
financée un point important cette
période de crise opération ce hangar et
c'est bien oui la france peut là peut se
la permettre comme en atteste la loi de
programmation militaire loi de
programmation militaire qui va être
discuté tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
et alors tu as mais ce que ces arguments
ont réussi à convaincre les sénateurs
écoutez on peut dire qu'il ya eu
largement un consensus dans l'hémicycle
déjà du côté de la droite à l'ump certes
on s'est interrogé jacques legendre
s'est demandé si la france était devenue
le gendarme de l'afrique après
l'intervention malienne voilà le tour de
l'opération centrafricaine il est
également intervenu pour dire qu'il
doutait fort que cette invention
n'allait pas durer mais cependant malgré
ces interrogations il a fini par salué
cette intervention les centristes
également part à la voix de jean-marie
golf auquel sont intervenus pour
souligner l'impérieuse nécessité de
cette opération
et finalement c'est du côté de la gauche
que sont venues les véritables
interrogations notamment les communistes
qui ont mis un véritable coup de pied
dans la fourmilière l'économiste qui
estime que cette opération n'est pas là
seulement pour satisfaire le devoir de
la france mais pour satisfaire les
intérêts économiques et stratégiques de
la france la france qui cherche à
reprendre la main sur les intérêts
économiques et stratégiques de la région
et tout cela avec l'aval de l'union
européenne du côté des écologistes
également on s'est interrogé on s'est
demandé mais pourquoi la france est-elle
donc seul dans cette intervention si
cette intervention et si nécessaire
interrogation qui a d'ailleurs été
reprise par jean louis carrère le
président socialiste de la commission
des affaires étrangères qui lui aussi
s'est demandé pourquoi la france était
seul et ce qui est pourquoi il y avait
un silence assourdissant de temps de
partenaires merci beaucoup tam alors
sans plus tarder direction l'hémicycle
pour écouter l'intervention de jean yves
le drian le ministre de la défense mais
tout d'abord l'hommage du sénat aux deux
soldats français tués ce matin à bangui
engagions le débat sur l'intervention
des forces armées françaises la
république centraficaine c'est que c'est
avec une grande émotion que je souhaite
rendre hommage aux deux soldats français
du 8e régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine le 8e rpima de
castres qui sont morts au combat cette
nuit à bangui le sénat tout entier salue
l'immense courage de ces deux hommes qui
ont fait le sacrifice de leur vie pour
défendre les valeurs universelles de
liberté
et de démocratie nous exprimons à leurs
familles et à leurs proches nos
condoléances les plus attristées nous
associons à la douleur à leur douleur
ainsi qu'à celles de leurs camarades de
régiment nos pensées vont également en
cette heure vers l'ensemble des
militaires déployés en république
centrafricaine pour rétablir la sécurité
et protéger les populations
le chers collègues je vous demande de
bien vouloir conserver une matinée une
minute de silence pour honorer la
mémoire des deux soldats morts au combat
la nuit dernière
l'ordre du jour appelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat sur
l'engagement des forces armées en
république centrafricaine dans le cadre
du mandat résultats de la résolution
2127 du conseil de sécurité des nations
unies en application de l'article 35
alinéa 2 de la constitution
la parole est à monsieur jean yves le
drian ministre de la défense
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
jeudi dernier
le président de la république s'est
adressé à la nation
pour annoncer l'intervention des forces
françaises en république centrafricaine
la décision d'engager nos forces armées
toujours une décision grave
nous venons de rendre hommage
aux deux soldats nicolas becker et
entonne le quinio
du 8e régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine de castres qui
ont fait cette nuit le sacrifice de leur
vie
mes pensées vont à leur famille
à leurs proches
auxquels j'exprime la solidarité de la
nation
et je transmets les condoléances les
plus attristées de l'ensemble du
gouvernement
en république centrafricaine aux hommes
interviennent en appui à la mission
internationale de soutien à ce pays la
miss k et sur la base d'un mandat du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
cette intervention était urgente et
nécessaire
quelques heures auparavant des miliciens
armés massacre est encore dans les rues
de bangui n'épargnant ni les femmes ni
les enfants munis de liste de victimes
et faisant du porte à porte pour les
traquer
le danger d'une telle situation le
président de la république l'avait
dénoncé à la tribune de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies en septembre
dernier
notre alarme était justifiée
le pays était bien au bord du gouffre
depuis la prise du pouvoir par des
rebelles de la celica le 24 mars 2013
les exactions l'arbitraire les pillages
le recrutement d'enfants-soldats les
villages brûlés les viols les
mutilations les exécutions sommaires
voilà à quoi s'est résumée la vie
quotidienne des populations civiles
victimes de la faillite de l'état
centrafricain
plus inquiétant encore
les affrontements entre groupes ont pris
récemment une tournure inter
communautaires et inter confessionnel
extrêmement dangereuse
cette spirale de la haine
aurait pu à tout moment déboucher sur un
enchaînement d'exactions et de
représailles entre chrétiens et
musulmans
l'anarchie en république centrafricaine
est aussi une menace pour une région
déjà fragile
les grands lacs les sous dans ce pays
enclavé entre le cameroun le tchad le
soudan le soudan du sud la république
démocratique du congo et le
congo-brazzaville ne doit en aucun cas
devenir un nouveau sanctuaire pour tous
les trafics et pour tous les groupes
terroristes
à cet égard c'est aussi notre sécurité
et celle de l'europe qui sont en cause
à cette crise sécuritaire s'est effondré
mans sécuritaire
s'ajoute une tragédie humanitaire
un habitant sur dix a dû abandonner son
foyer
70000 centrafricains ont déjà quitté le
pays et 2 millions 300 mille personnes
ont besoin d'une assistance en urgence
face à ce drame la france pouvait elle
ne rien faire la france pouvait elle
rester sourde aux appels à l'aide des
autorités centrafricaines et de nos
partenaires de l'union africaine
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
la france
l'inaction n'était pas une option
attendre c'était prendre le risque d'un
désastre
attendre c'était nous exposer au risque
d'une intervention ultérieure beaucoup
plus coûteuse est beaucoup plus
difficile
cette décision fait suite aux efforts
déployés depuis plusieurs mois en faveur
d'une réponse collective à cette
tragédie en plein coeur de l'afrique
il ya eu d'abord le message dans l'âme
du présent la république à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies je les
rappeler
il ya eu ensuite
l'encouragement aux pays de la région à
renforcer les troupes qu'ils avaient
commencé à déployer et à user de leur
toute leur influence pour que les
parties cessent les violences et
reprennent le chemin de la transition
politique
c'est la france qui a saisi le conseil
de sécurité qui a obtenu que deux
résolution soit votée à l'unanimité
à l'unanimité
la résolution
21-27 adopté la semaine dernière donne
mandat à la force africaine de
stabiliser la république centrafricaine
est de protéger les civils elle nous
permet d'appuyer cette force
c'est encore la france qui a su
convaincre ses partenaires
internationaux
d'apporter leur soutien politique
logistiques et financiers à cet effort
international de stabilisation
le cadre de l'opération 100 gary c'est
incontestable
la france agit sur la base d'un mandat
des nations unies elles répondent à
l'appel lancé par l'union africaine 13
novembre dernier elle répond également à
une demande d'assistance des autorités
de transition africaine
nos objectifs sont clairement
circonscrit
premièrement rétablir la sécurité en
république centrafricaine enrayer la
spirale d'exactions et la dérive
confessionnelles et permettre le retour
des organisations humanitaires ainsi que
le déploiement des structures étatiques
de base
deuxièmement
favorisé la montée en puissance rapide
de la miss k et permettent son plein
déploiement opérationnel
la miss k doit en effet être en mesure
d'assurer le contrôle de la situation
sécuritaire de désarmer les milices et
de faciliter la transition politique
le président de la république l'a dit
notre intervention sur rapide elle n'a
pas vocation à durer
elle est pleinement cohérente avec le
message du sommet de l'elysée sur la
paix et la sécurité en afrique la
sécurité de l'afrique relève de la
responsabilité des africains
nos forces sont engagés dans l'urgence
en soutien des contingents africains de
la miss kha dans l'action a déjà
commencé et va se renforcer
l'union africaine a en effet annoncé
qu'elle porterait rapidement sa présence
sur le terrain de 2400 à 6000 hommes ces
sommes viennent de tous les pays de la
région
le désengagement de nos forces
commencera dès que la situation le
permettra en fonction de l'évolution sur
le terrain et de la montée en puissance
des capacités opérationnelles des forces
africaines ce doit être la sphère de
quelques mois
nous savons qu'il faudra du temps pour
désarmer les milices formées de
nouvelles forces de sécurité
centrafricaine et mener à bien un
processus électoral c'est le rôle dans
la durée de la musque à la résolution 21
27 prévoient qu'une opération de
maintien de la paix des nations unies
pourra si le conseil de sécurité en
décide lui succéder pour la conforter et
pour lui apporter un cas plus robuste y
compris en matière de financement et
l'union européenne pourra également y
contribuer notamment grâce aux
instruments de la politique de sécurité
et de défense commune
je salue la rapidité la qualité de
l'action que nos forces mènent sur le
terrain
nous avons pu grâce à la complémentarité
entre notre dispositif prépositionné
dans la région et les forces en alerte
en france porté en deux jours notre
présent sur place à 1600 hommes
nous avons pu grâce au renfort rapide
qui ont été déployés à bangui et
ailleurs bossangoa en particulier éviter
des massacres de masse alors que la
situation dans la capitale devenait
critique
vous avez lu les témoignages des
observateurs et des organisations non
gouvernementales dont je salue
l'engagement
nous sommes aux côtés des forces
africaines
sécurisé les sites les plus sensibles
notamment l'aéroport et des zones de
regroupement nos compatriotes qui sont
près de 800 dans 500 binationaux il
assure une présence constante par des
patrouilles dont la vertu dissuasive
commence à jouer pleinement et déjà il
participe aux actions de cantonnement et
de désarmement des groupes armés afin de
rétablir calme et sécurité il favorise
le retour à des conditions d'un
fonctionnement normal des structures
étatiques indispensable au règlement
durable de la situation dans le pays
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
soyons clairs la république
centrafricaine n'est pas le mali la
situation sur le terrain diffèrent les
groupes armés ne poursuivent pas les
mêmes objectifs
et pourtant on peut entendre à nouveau
les mêmes questionnements
j'entends des questionnements sur les
moyens oui la france a la capacité
d'agir aujourd'hui le financement de
l'opération ce hangar essais prévus au
budget de l'état comme en atteste la
clause de garantie figurant dans le
projet de loi de programmation militaire
que nous examinerons tout à l'heure
la france le pourra aussi demain dans le
cadre défini par cette loi avec un
format parfaitement adapté à la conduite
simultanée d'opérations telles que
celles engagées au mali et en république
centrafricaine
j'entends aussi quelques questionnements
sur notre posture mais ils ne sont rares
non la france n'agit pas en gendarme de
l'afrique et l'assument tout simplement
ses responsabilités internationales
elles répondent à l'appel de ses
partenaires africains et fait face à
l'urgence absolue de prévenir
spiral2 massacre
le sommet de l'elysée pour la paix et la
sécurité en afrique a été l'occasion
d'un message unanime de tous les
africains sur la nécessité de renforcer
les capacités africaines de réponse aux
crises sur le continent
la mise en place d'une vraie force
panafricaine de réaction rapide
mobilisera dans les mois à venir
l'afrique et ses partenaires
j'entends aussi quelques questions sur
l' isolement non la france n'est pas
seule
elle bénéficie du soutien politique de
tous les membres du conseil de sécurité
le secrétaire général des nations unies
a encore lancé vendredi dernier un appel
d'urgence sur la situation en république
centrafricaine la france agit par
ailleurs aux côtés des africains
regroupés au sein de la miss kha l'union
européenne l'accompagnent depuis le
début le président du conseil européen
qui participait au sommet de l'elysée a
souligné les risques que la
déstabilisation des pays africains
faisait peser sur la sécurité de
l'europe toute entière
l'europe agissent sur le terrain avec la
mise en place hier d'un pont aérien
entre douala et bangui pour acheminer
l'aide humanitaire indispensable
l'europe apporte ses capacités de
financement et les états membres qui
disposent de moyens opérationnels
nécessaires et hi media s'engage
également et sans attendre le royaume
uni l'allemagne ont mis des moyens
aériens à disposition de la france la
belgique et des africains la belgique se
prépare à apporter son appui d'autres
pays encore sont en relation avec nous
et nous ont fait savoir leur
disponibilité et je les en remercie
d'avancé
les etats unis fourniront dans les
prochains jours
des capacités de transport pour les
contingents africains et se sont engagés
à hauteur de 40 millions de dollars pour
la miss kha l'union européenne la
finance déjà à hauteur de 50 millions
d'euros et examine comment s'engager
très rapidement dans le domaine de la
formation
car au delà de l'urgence il faut
préparer l'avenir et cet avenir passe
notamment
par la restructuration des forces de
sécurité et par la restauration de
l'autorité de l'état et des services
publics
il faudra surtout que la transition
politique soit mené à son terme
trop longtemps la république
centrafricaine a été ballotté au gré de
pouvoir faible d'une gouvernance
défaillante et de l'ingérence d'acteurs
extérieurs
notre volonté est de tourner cette page
c'est cet esprit aura ce soir le
président de la république à l'occasion
de sa visite à bangui au retour de
l'afrique du sud
avec les centrafricains
les pays de la région ont opposé les
contours d'un processus de transition
devant aboutir à des élections les
présidentielles et législatives et
transparente libre le plus tôt possible
les autorités afrique centrafricaine se
sont engagés à mener à bien cette
transition la communauté internationale
fera preuve de la plus grande vigilance
il en va de la renaissance de la
république centrafricaine
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
les dis la décision d'engager nos forces
armées est toujours une décision grave
en ces circonstances
l'unité de la nation et de l'ensemble
des forces politiques est indispensable
en recevant ce matin les présidents des
deux assemblées de leurs groupes
politiques et des commissions
compétentes
le premier ministre a déjà pu constater
une large convergence de vues
cette unité ou à devons à nos soldats
qui au péril de leur vie agissent sur un
nouveau théâtre
et je ne soulignerai jamais assez leur
courage et leur professionnalisme
cette unité nous la devons aussi au
peuple centrafricain
qui traverse depuis trop longtemps les
épreuves et qui est en droit de
prétendre à des lendemains meilleurs
la crise actuelle pourra j'en suis
persuadé être surmontées et céder le pas
à la reprise du dialogue
intercommunautaire à la réconciliation
nationale et à une perspective de
développement la france saura faire
preuve de solidarité
cette unité ne devons enfin à l'afrique
notamment aux pays d'afrique centrale
qui se sont mobilisés de manière
exemplaire et qui ont demandé l'aide de
la france
la france assume ses responsabilités
internationales et tient parole en étant
à leur côté elle respecte ses valeurs
celles qui sont au coeur de notre
république
mesdames et messieurs et les sénateurs
un des plus grands hommes que le
continent africain est connue disait ce
monde doit être celui de la démocratie
et du respect des droits humains un
monde libéré des affres de la pauvreté
de la faim du dénuement et de
l'ignorance
épargné par les guerres civiles et des
agressions extérieures et débarrassée de
la grande tragédie vécue par des
millions de réfugiés
cet homme c'était nelson mandela
c'est la liberté du peuple centrafricain
son aspiration à retrouver la paix et la
sécurité et a bénéficié de l'assistance
humanitaire la plus élémentaire que nous
sommes défendre aujourd'hui avec les
forces africaines cette cause est juste
elle correspond à l'idée même que la
france se fait de sa place dans le monde
le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont fait le choix de
l'action
à l'heure d'assumer à nouveau cette
responsabilité je sais que nous
continuerons à nous rassembler pour que
nos soldats soient plus forts et que les
objectifs de la france soit pleinement
atteint je vous remercie de votre
attention
un merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes je passe la parole
à jacques legendre pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
pour la deuxième fois cette année le
président de la république engage des
troupes françaises dans une opération
extérieure
se tient tout d'abord au nom du groupe
ump a adressé à nos soldats et leurs
familles un message de soutien
sur tous les bancs du sénat nous sommes
reconnaissants j'en suis certain à nos
soldats pour leur preuve
professionnalisme et leur courage et
l'annoncé de la mort de deux d'entre eux
aujourd'hui en opération nous touche
profondément
nos soldats sont la fierté de notre pays
quand ils concrétisent ainsi l'action de
notre diplomatie qui n'a pas ménagé sa
peine au conseil de sécurité des nations
unies pour faire adopter la résolution
21 27 malgré les atermoiements
hésitations de certains de nos
partenaires
mais pourquoi après le mali intervenir
une nouvelle fois et cette fois ci en
centrafrique
serions nous devenus les gendarmes de
l'afrique nous n'avons pas vocation à
jouer ce rôle ne devons pas revendiquer
ce rôle car les états africains
évidemment sont indépendants depuis
maintenant des décennies
mais s'agissant du mali et puis du
centrafrique il s'agit de territoires
auxquels nous unissent encore des liens
affectifs et culturels puissant et qui
si nous n'étions pas intervenus risquait
rapidement de sombrer dans le chaos
je connais bien le centrafrique c'est un
pays où j'ai été coopérant en qualité de
volontaire du service national jadis
j'ai enseigné le français dans un
collège de brousse ce pays de six cent
mille kilomètres carrés un peu plus
grand que la france peuplé à l'époque
d'un million et demi d'habitants ils
sont maintenant quatre millions et demi
on le connaissait jadis sous le nom du
bandit charrie il le deuxième territoire
africain à rejoindre la france libre en
1940 n'oublions pas l'aide que ces
soldats nous ont apporté au moment le
plus sombre de notre histoire
ce pays a été conduit à l'indépendance
par un homme remarquable
l'abbé barthélemy boganda il avait une
vision il avait il rêvait de construire
états unis d'afrique latine il avait
constitué une formation dénommée
mouvement d'évolution sociale de
l'afrique noire il voulait conduire
l'afrique centrale vers la modernité
dans la coopération avec la france il
avait donné à son pays cette belle
devise en langue locale le sango jo
creusot c'est à dire un homme est un
homme d il est mort très vite victime
d'un accident d'avion à l'aube de
l'indépendance et son pays a connu une
spirale de coups d'état et de désordre
qui le mène aujourd'hui au bord de
l'effondrement
quand j'ai connu bandits mes chers
collègues on l'appelait bangui la
coquette et c'était une belle petite
ville on la surnomme maintenant et
depuis des années hélas bangui la
roquette avions-nous le droit la
possibilité de ne rien faire vous
faisions nous laisser massacrer la
population de bandits à quelques
kilomètres d'une forces françaises
stationnées sur l'aéroport de cette
capitale
comment pourrions-nous justifier devant
notre conscience et devant l'opinion
internationale le choix de ne rien faire
le jour même où nous pleurons tous
unanimement la disparition de nelson
mandela qui a su lui aussi comme
barthélémy boganda conduire son peuple à
l'indépendance en voulant dépasser les
différences de couleurs et d'ethnie ce
n'était pas possible
il nous fallait agir il faut simplement
regretter que nous soyons les seuls une
fois de plus à avoir la capacité et la
volonté d'agir actuellement dans cette
partie de l'afrique
c'est d'abord au continent africain
qu'il appartient de régler les problèmes
qui se déroule sur son sol l'aide à
l'afrique ne relève pas seulement de la
france une devrions obtenir nos amis
européens autre chose qu'un soutien tout
de même timide monsieur le ministre même
s'il comporte aussi quelques facilités
de transport la grande bretagne la
belgique le portugal et même l'allemagne
l'italie et l'espagne ont été aussi
présent sur le contient africain
l'europe et l'afrique ont un avenir
beaucoup plus étroitement liés que
beaucoup de personnes ne le pense
l'europe saura-t-elle définir une
politique africaine ambitieuse
respectueuse de l'union africaine en
construction est tourné vers un
véritable développement qui seul peut
empêcher le renouvellement des crises
il faut dire aussi aux français qui
s'interroge notre engagement
centrafrique que cette décision est tout
à fait conforme aux intérêts de la
france
nous avons empêché au mali
l'instauration d'une dictature
religieuse
obscurantiste et brutale pouvions nous
laisser s'installer au coeur de
l'afrique un espace de non droit
accueillant sur son sol tous les
trafiquants de drogue d'ivoire d'armes
et tous les fanatiques qui auraient pu y
trouver refuge
coupeurs de route venus du darfour où
des confins du tchad et du soudan du
nord comme du sud
métastases de boko haram cette rébellion
sanguinaire qui désole le nigeria menace
maintenant le cameroun et enlève nos
ressortissants
armée de résistance du seigneur la lra
sortie de l'ouganda et qui a déjà brûlé
temps de village centrafricain le
centrafrique que j'ai connu et aimé
n'était pas déchiré par les haines
religieuses les pygmées les baiia de
l'ouest centrafricain animistes ou
chrétiens et les peul bororo de la
région de boire ou nos troupes ont été
acclamés samedi quand existait sans
heurts c'est l'irruption d'éléments
violents armés venus d'ailleurs qui a
changé la situation
le processus amorcé il ya dix ans déjà
lors de la prise de pouvoir par le
général bozizé se rend forme se renforce
aujourd'hui les menaces sont récentes
l'état centrafricain a pratiquement
disparu
la capitale bangui est en proie aux
affrontements dans la brousse il n'ya
plus d'administrations plus de police
plus de gendarmerie plus de
représentants de l'état l'état
centrafricain s'est effondré comme
quelques autres dans le monde il faudra
du temps beaucoup de temps pour le
reconstruire et d'abord pour garantir
l'intégrité de son territoire et rendre
la parole au peuple centrafricain par
des élections véritablement libres et
puis ensuite et le plus vite possible
aider à sa reconstruction et à son
développement quant à payer dans cet
état mes chers collègues il ne faut pas
aider un court moment est rentré chez
soi il faut pouvoir avec le maximum de
partenaires et dans la durée accompagner
cet état pour lui éviter de nouvelles
crises
actuellement les paysans en brousse
n'ose plus mais la disette est déjà
présente dans un pays qui devrait
pouvoir nourrir sa population
ne parlons pas des investissements
étrangers qui bien sûr sont maintenant
complètement arrêté il y a urgence à
agir mes chers collègues je pense même
que la communauté internationale a déjà
beaucoup trop tardé c'est pourquoi
j'avais interpellé monsieur le ministre
des affaires étrangères il ya quelques
semaines ici en m'inquiétant déjà de la
situation je ne reprocherai sûrement pas
au président de la république d'avoir
décidé vu l'urgence d'engager nos
troupes dès que les conditions étaient
réunies au conseil de sécurité à new
york je me réjouis simplement qu'un
débat sur cet engagement soit maintenant
organiser comme l'a voulu la révision
constitutionnelle
proposée par nicolas sarkozy en 2008 et
qui en modifiant l'article 35 de la
constitution à renforcer le rôle du
parlement tout en laissant au chef de
l'état la possibilité de réagir vite
face aux massacres et aux tragédies
c'est une chance pour notre diplomatie
que de n'être pas tributaire a priori de
tractations partisane mais il est tout à
fait normal que le prison la république
au bout de quatre mois doit obtenir du
parlement l'autorisation de poursuivre
une opération extérieure
faudra-t-il qu'il en soit ainsi dans
quatre mois
je le crains où je le crois car nous ne
devons pas nous faire d'illusions
cette intervention nécessaire est aussi
périlleuse certes les conditions
climatiques et politiques sont
différentes de celles du nord mali mais
peut-on sécuriser rapidement un pays
grand comme la france avec seulement
1600 militaires français et quelques
milliers de militaires africains et il
ne faut pas sous-estimer la combativité
des scellés cas souvent redoutable qui
ont connu ailleurs d'autres conflits et
en sont sortis
endurci et très violent les événements
de cette nuit hélas le confirme alors il
est nécessaire que les nations unies
l'europe s'engage vraiment à nos côtés
car la france à une admirable armée mais
son volume ses moyens en sont de plus en
plus contraints en cette période de
débats budgétaires je voudrais redire
notre conviction que la faute est
essentielle et toujours de prendre des
engagements internationaux que nos
moyens militaires et diplomatiques ne
permettrait pas d'honorer nous sommes
membres du conseil de sécurité
c'est une charge et c'est une chance et
nous devons y rester mais nous le sommes
aussi parce que nous disposons d'une
dissuasion nucléaire d'une véritable
armée et d'un réseau diplomatique très
étoffé réduire encore les moyens de nos
armées de notre diplomatie
serait à terme rapide nous condamne être
plus qu'une nation de second ou le
troisième rang après bien d'autres
crises c'est aussi la leçon à tirer de
ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il ya parfois des raccourcis saisissants
alors que vient de s'achever à un
nouveau sommet france afrique nous voici
tout à la fois engagé une fois de plus
sur ce continent au secours d'une
population menacée et plonger aussi dans
la peine universel ressenti à la halle
annonce de la mort de nelson mandela on
le voit bien la france et l'afrique ont
tissé de tels liens que tout
naturellement ce qui se passe en 9 en
afrique et on partait en afrique
francophone prend chez nous une
singulière résonance comme il est vrai
aussi que l'afrique qui ne regarde plus
seulement vers les anciennes puissances
coloniales n'est néanmoins jamais
indifférente à ce qui nous concerne et
continue à attendre beaucoup et peut
être trop de nous cette empathie ce
n'est pas ce qu'on appelle la
françafrique c'est le sentiment réel de
lien particulier et je veux souhaiter
que la jeunesse africaine et la jeunesse
française puisse continuer à échanger à
se rencontrer à se comprendre j'ai eu la
chance avec beaucoup d'autres jeunes
français jadis de fer en afrique ce
service national qui pouvait être utile
et qui joue nous a surtout beaucoup
appris je souhaite que la jeunesse
française et la jeunesse africaine
puisse continuer à se rencontrer à se
fréquenter ça me paraît très important
pour l'avenir
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une fois de plus aujourd'hui la france
dans l'urgence s'engage par fidélité à
ses valeurs mais cet engagement ne nous
dispense pas d'aidé d'abord ce que nous
avons rendu indépendant de nous à
acquérir progressivement les moyens
réels de cette indépendance
un homme politique centrafricain
monsieur regroupant des avait écrit un
livre intitulé l'afrique sans la france
la france fort heureusement répond
encore une fois à l'appel de l'afrique
l'afrique n'est pas sans la france est
ce qu'il faut vouloir c'est bâtir une
vraie solidarité entre la france
l'europe et l'afrique pour notre bien
commun je vous remercie
merci la parole est à jean marie bockel
pour le groupe udi uc
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre et dams et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues après
l'intervention forte et juste et
émouvante de notre collègue que le
gendre fois m'exprimer au nom de groupes
udi us et l'intervention des forces
armées françaises en rca en a peu en
appui de la mission internationale de
soutien à la centrafrique sous conduite
africaine la miss kha bien répondre en
effet une situation de danger extrême
pour les populations civiles alors que
les violences interethniques et
interreligieuses menace de plonger un
peu plus le pays dans le chaos il y va
aussi comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre de notre sécurité
monsieur le ministre comme nous l'avions
fait lors de l'intervention au mali et
dans un esprit de responsabilité et
d'union nationale nous apportons notre
soutien à cette décision du président de
la république qui s'inscrit dans la
légalité internationale conformément à
la résolution 21 27 des nations unies
permettez moi à mon tour de saluer la
mémoire de nos deux soldats décédés
cette nuit engagés dans l'opération sans
garris qui sont tombés hier au combat et
il y associe aussi ceux qui ont fait le
sacrifice suprême au mali lors de cette
intervention qui se poursuit également
si les objectifs de cette opération
d'ores et déjà été annoncée par le
président hollande désarmement des
milices et objets armés stabilisation du
pays en vue d'élections libres et
pluralistes
nous attendons
cision non pas sur la situation
d'aujourd'hui ça a été fait sur le
format et la durée mais tout au long de
cette opération car comme vous l'avait
dit ce matin à matignon c'est une
opération complexe et on ne peut pas
vous demander de me dire précisément
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en sera dans deux
trois mois mais nous comptons sur vous
bien sûr pour nous informer informer nos
concitoyens et puis aussi nous apporter
au fur et à mesure des précisions sur le
rôle qu'entend jouer la france dans le
processus de stabilisation et de
reconstruction
quoi qu'il en soit certains enjeux
d'ordre sécuritaire politique ou
humanitaire sont d'ores et déjà
perceptibles la première priorité
consiste évidemment au rétablissement
d'un climat de sécurité sur lequel les
efforts de reconstruction seront vains
la république centrafricaine est devenu
depuis plusieurs mois une zone grise où
prospèrent des bandes armées avec des
pillages et exactions viols massacres
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de la
coalition de rebelles c'est les cas la
situation sécuritaire s'est dégradée à
bangui et dans le reste du pays en
raison d'affrontements opposant des
éléments cdk à des groupes d'auto
défense laissant apparaître le spectre
d'un génocide inter religieux oui c'est
vrai il était temps et en même temps il
fallait le faire dans la légalité
internationale
vous l'avez dit c'est donc le moment le
renforcement du dispositif militaire
français ne saurait néanmoins remplacer
l'indispensable est nécessaire montée en
puissance de la force africaine il en va
de la responsabilité partagée des
africains face aux défis sécuritaires de
la région cette africanisation passe
bien sûr par le renforcement de la miss
k qui mobilise à ce jour environ 2500
soldats sous la bannière de l'union
africaine avec l'appui de la communauté
économique des états d'afrique centrale
à l'issue du récent sommet de l'elysée
sur la paix et la sécurité l'union
africaine a décidé de porter cette force
en centrafrique à 6000 hommes contre
3600 initialement prévu c'est bien des
incertitudes persistent cependant sur sa
capacité à se déployer cette force
rapidement et efficacement
quand on voit par exemple
les difficultés que rencontre la
minustah au mali dont les contingents
sont souvent sous entraînés sous équipés
plus généralement force est de constater
que la mutualisation par les états
membres de l'union africaine de leurs
moyens civils militaires et policiers
pour participer à la résolution des
conflits à l'échelle régionale reste
encore balbutiante même si on a pu le
constater récemment à l'union africaine
la volonté existe mais il ya encore du
chemin du travail pourtant la mise en
place d'une véritable architecture de
sécurité africaines disposant d'une
force de réaction rapide demeure plus
que jamais une nécessité comme
d'ailleurs le soulignait le rapport que
nous avons co signé avec jeanny lorgeoux
et d'autres collègues commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense du
président carrère la constitution d'une
telle force africaine continue de faire
face à des problèmes d'interopérabilité
et de financement outre le manque de
volonté politique de certains états
c'est bien d'ailleurs que la france se
soit engagé ce week end à former 20
mille soldats africains par an pour
cette force dont l'objectif est d'être
opérationnel dès 2015
l'europe devrait également prendre sa
part à cet effort de soutien aux forces
africaines car nos deux continents sont
liés et des enjeux de sécurité ne
connaissent pas de frontières à l'image
du terrorisme or si nous saluons la
prompte réaction de notre pays un rca
nous ne pouvons que déplorer une fois de
plus l'absence totale de décisions
européennes
certes l'union européenne a salué le feu
vert donné par l'onu à une intervention
des forces africaines et françaises dont
catherine ashton évoquant même un
soutien substantiel pour répondre à
l'urgence et la gravité de la situation
mais que compte faire l'europe de
manière concrète pour nous soutenir
militairement
logistiquement ou financièrement dans
cette opération
du côté des pays européens le royaume
uni a proposé une aide logistique limité
à la france mais l'envoi de troupes
britanniques ne semble pas être une
option pole man sur la table en tout cas
à notre connaissance ce matin lors de la
réunion à matignon vous l'avez dit le
premier ministre l'a dit d'autres pays
européens se sont manifestés vous avez
parlé des allemands des polonais enfin
d'autres pays encore pour apporter ce
soutien logistique et j'allais dire et
et plus si affinités enfin nous verrons
bien mais ce serait bien évidemment que
même de manière symbolique peut-être il
puisse y avoir une présence d'une
manière ou d'une autre sur le terrain de
certains de ces pays
aussi monsieur le ministre pourquoi ne
pas plaider auprès de nos partenaires
européens pour le déploiement du groupe
tactique européen battle group dont
l'objectif est justement de pouvoir
participer rapidement à des opérations à
l'étranger
créé en 2007 ce groupement n'a encore
jamais été utilisée sur un théâtre
d'opération pour le second semestre 2013
il comprend environ 15 cents militaires
de cinq pays dont le royaume-uni qui le
dirige ce déploiement permettrait rêvons
un peu de mettre en pratique l'idée de
défense européenne à quelques jours du
conseil européen consacré à cette
question dans le même temps le
rétablissement de la sécurité en rca
doit permettre la mise en oeuvre au plus
vite d'un processus de transition
politique auxquelles nous apportons tout
notre soutien
j'avais saluer il ya quelques semaines
la signature à bangui par le président
de transition de la république
centrafricaine michel je te dia le
premier ministre nicolas tiangaye qu'ils
croient être en france en ce moment et
le président du conseil national de
transition la pacte républicain sous
l'égide de la communauté de sant'egidio
qui est souvent intervenu avec succès
dans bien des conflits
dramatiques sur la planète et notamment
le continent africain je pense au
mozambique
lorsque la guerre civile était faisait
rage dans ce pays ce pacte républicain
issu des pourparlers de paix et 6 et 7
septembre dernier exclut la violence
comme moyen d'accéder au pouvoir et
réaffirme la nécessité de renforcer des
institutions et de travailler durant
l'actuelle phase de transition politique
pour préparer le pays et ses structures
à la démocratie il est désormais urgent
que l'ensemble des acteurs mettent en
oeuvre ces principes directeurs dans une
démarche inclusive et de réconciliation
à même d'apaiser les tensions en cours
vie entre les communautés piqué
religieuse le groupe u10 uc est
particulièrement attachée au bon
déroulement jusqu'à son terme du
processus politique devant aboutir au
début de l'année 2015 ou peut être avant
vous nous le dira et à des élections
libres et transparentes
cette transition ne pourra s'opérer sans
le désarmement la démobilisation et la
réintégration de tous les groupes armés
présents en rca enfin et pour conclure
il est urgent d'apporter une réponse
immédiate à lagrasse crise à la grave
crise humanitaire que traverse la rca
l'accès à l'aide humanitaire reste en
effet très limité en raison du climat
d'insécurité et les besoins sont énormes
dans le pays ne l'oublions pas non plus
alors que effectivement les opérations
militaires sont en cours le chaos que
connaît ce pays depuis décembre 2012 a
provoqué la fuite de plus de 60000
centrafricain vers d'autres pays plus de
415 mille ont été déplacées dans leur
propre pays et selon la secrétaire
générale adjointe de l'onu aux affaires
humanitaires
la moitié de la population a besoin d'
aide humanitaire dans ce pays et 1,3
million un million d'habitants de ce
pays a besoin d'une aide alimentaire
d'urgence l'union européenne a déjà
débloqué une aide humanitaire de 20
millions d'euros depuis le début de
l'année on parle à présent de 50
millions d'euros supplémentaires si le
déploiement des forces françaises et
africaines devait faciliter
l'acheminement de l'aide beaucoup reste
à faire nous appelons la tenue d'une
conférence de bailleurs de fonds pour
répondre à cette situation d'urgence je
crois que c'est d'ailleurs envisagé est
ainsi enclencher un processus de
reconstruction indispensable car sans
développement il n'y aura pas de
sécurité durable ici comme ailleurs hier
au mali en côte d'ivoire ou en libye
aujourd'hui en rca la france démontre
même si celui des opérations sont très
différentes qu'elle est en mesure
d'intervenir rapidement lors d'une crise
grave à travers une capacité de
projection et des forces prépositionnées
alors que les zones d'instabilité
persiste en afrique notamment dans la
zone sahélienne avec un risque de
déstabilisation régionale la solution ne
peut néanmoins venir uniquement de l'
usage des forces françaises dont les
moyens se contracte du fait de la
contrainte budgétaire
la mobilisation de partenaires européens
de l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale est essentielle mais
c'est surtout les mettre dans une
véritable architecture de sécurité
africaine doté d'une capacité
d'intervention robuste sous l'égide de
l'union africaine et des organisations
subrégionale qui permettra d'assurer à
long terme la sécurité et la stabilité
du continent c'est bien là notre intérêt
mutuel de part et d'autre de la
méditerranée
dans cette attente monsieur le ministre
le groupe u10 et nous apporte son
soutien dans cette décision d'engager
nos forces armées en centrafrique marque
également sa solidarité à nos soldats
qui servent courageusement sous nos
couleurs que ce soit en centrafrique au
mali ou sur les différents théâtres
extérieurs l'afrique est notre avenir
cette afrique convoité diverses c'est
aussi un peu le message de nelson
mandela et bien cette afrique nous
devons aujourd'hui la considérer d'égal
à égal c'est également notre avenir
merci la parole à michelle demessine
pour le groupe crc
d'où un petit groupe tient
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
la disparition de nelson mandela
résonne douloureusement avec les
tragiques événements de centrafrique cet
homme après avoir lutté la majeure
partie de sa vie contre l'inhumanité
suprême qu'est la ségrégation raciale a
réussi à éviter un désastre à son pays
en prônant la réconciliation entre ses
différentes composantes pour construire
une afrique du sud libre démocratique
non raciale progressant sur la voie du
progrès économique et social
nelson mandela disparaît alors qu'un
petit pays du continent est en proie à
une extrême pauvreté et au
sous-développement source d'affrontement
entre les populations
la centrafrique sombre depuis plusieurs
mois dans un chaos indescriptible
de violence et de massacre et menacent
d'y entraîner toute une région
depuis vendredi dernier nos troupes
interviennent dans ce pays avec comme
première mission de mettre fin aux
exactions de toutes sortes contre les
populations civiles de permettre
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire de
désarmer les bandes qui sévissent
cette difficile mission a déjà fait de
victimes au sein du 8e régiment
parachutiste d'infanterie de marine je
salue ici le courage et l'abnégation de
ces hommes qui sont allés jusqu'au
sacrifice suprême ces jeunes hommes pour
remplir la mission
que leur avait confié notre pays les
informations qui nous parviennent de
bangui
les images que nous avons vues en boucle
durant le week-end
la gravité de la situation et les scènes
d'horreur provoque légitimement d'abord
des réactions passionnelles
qui laisse peu de place à une réflexion
raisonnée face à cette situation qui se
dégrade et de semaine en semaine il
fallait sans doute intervenir en urgence
le président de la république en prenant
une nouvelle fois en moins d'un an la
décision d'engager donc trouvent sur le
continent africain à assumer ses
responsabilités au nom de la france
certes nous devions agir mais dans de
telles conditions cette opération est
elle menée en mesurant pleinement toutes
nos responsabilités et toute la portée
de cette décision et de nos choix
cinq jours après le début de l'opération
dénommée sans gary l'intérêt de ce débat
parlementaire est donc maintenant au
delà des apparences et des évidences de
prendre le temps de réfléchir avec
lucidité aux conditions et à la forme de
notre intervention d'en mesurer les
conséquences et d'envisager l'évolution
de la situation pour préparer l'avenir
cette intervention a certes la
légitimité que lui conforme que lui
confère la légalité internationale
puisqu'elle résulte d'une résolution
adoptée à l'initiative de la france à
l'unanimité des membres du conseil de
sécurité
concrètement cette résolution donne
mandat à nos forces pour intervenir afin
de rétablir la sécurité en appui des
troupes africaines de la mission
internationale de soutien à la
centrafrique la mise qu'à placer sous le
chapitre 7 de la charte des nations
unies qui permet le recours à la force
pour faire appliquer les résolutions est
les autorise ainsi je cite à prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
soutenir la miss kha dans
l'accomplissement de son mandat la
résolution envisage enfin la
transformation éventuelle de la miss kha
en force de maintien de la paix de l'onu
quand je cite les conditions le
permettront du point de vue de la
légalité internationale le mad le mandat
est donc fondée juridiquement et les
relativement clair il reste néanmoins
qu'en pratique la mise en oeuvre d'une
opération militaire
et surtout la suite politiques qui en
découlent se révèle plus compliqué que
le simple vote d'une résolution des
nations unies
outre les difficultés techniques d'une
opération qui comprendra avec les forces
panafricaine environ 5000 hommes vous
vous défendez aujourd'hui de vouloir
vous investir directement dans le
règlement politique de cette crise et
plus proclamer que vous laisserez au
plus vite la place aux nations unies
elles sont encore possibles après avoir
préparé est engagée seule cette
opération en centrafrique notre pays est
certainement le plus mal placé
en l'absence d'institutions étatiques
depuis des décennies pour agir en
avant-garde sur la transition politique
et le développement économique dans ce
pays qui a longtemps été sous notre
tutelle nous serons à juste titre
suspecté de vouloir nous substituer aux
centrafricains eux-mêmes et de ne
défendre que nos propres intérêts
pourquoi avoir persisté à intervenir
seul alors que le président de la
république s'était engagé à ne plus
s'ingérer dans les crises en afrique et
entretenir des relations d'un type
nouveau avec ces pays
monsieur le ministre il faut préciser la
stratégie du gouvernement dans cette
opération
quel objectif poursuivant nous
réellement pourquoi et comment avec qui
avec quels moyens la france va-t-elle
gérer cette nouvelle crise au centre de
l'afrique la déclaration du gouvernement
qui vient de précéder ce débat ne nous a
pas apporté les clarifications que nous
attendions d'ailleurs contrairement à
l'intervention au mali le trouble voire
le rejet qui existe aujourd'hui dans
l'opinion publique à l'égard de
l'engagement dans ce pays est révélateur
au delà d'une opposition qui c'est vrai
ne pourrait être que passagère et
s'expliquer par la situation économique
vit actuellement notre pays je pense
surtout que nos compatriotes sont
essentiellement réticents et sceptique
sur l'efficacité la capacité de ses
interventions militaires plus ou moins
ponctuels à résoudre les crises dans ces
pays et à agir sur les causes qui les
provoque il s'interroge également sur le
coût de ces opérations pour nos finances
publiques
puisqu'elles se font au détriment
d'autres priorités et puis il ne faut
pas céder aux sentiments ni aux
illusions la faillite centrafricaine ne
date pas de ces dernières semaines cette
faillite est aussi très concrètement due
à une profonde crise économique et
sociale résultant de l'effondrement des
cours des produits agricoles locaux
disons clairement les choses les
politiques successives de la france
porte une large part de responsabilité
dans la situation de ce pays car nous y
avons souvent joué un rôle d' influence
discutable en soutenant des
gouvernements peu recommandables et de
plus notre pays a soutenu et soutient
encore des les institutions
internationales qui applique à ces pays
des politiques ultra libérales qui
asphyxient leurs économies et plongent
leur population dans la misère
aujourd'hui nous intervenons in extremis
dans l'urgence alors que la situation se
dégrader depuis de nombreux mois que
n'ont eu de cesse de nous alerter les
ong présentes sur le terrain ce pays
était déjà au bord du gouffre au mois de
mars et peut être n'avons nous pas
suffisamment réagi lorsque les opposants
au président bozizé ont pris le pouvoir
avec le soutien du tchad quelles
initiatives diplomatiques auprès de la
communauté internationale et des pays de
la région notre pays at il pris pour
empêcher cet engrenage fatal s'il y en a
eu reconnaissant qu'elles ont été
particulièrement discrète et peu
efficace votre gouvernement s'est résolu
à éteindre cet incendie généralisé pour
se lancer en héros solitaire dans une de
ces opérations militaires qui deviennent
malheureusement notre spécialité dans
les relations internationales de cette
partie du monde mais quelle est votre
politique dans cette région au delà des
discours convenus et de la promesse
d'organiser au plus vite des élections
le gouvernement n'est pas véritablement
en mesure de présenter à la
représentation nationale les esquisses
d'une solution politique à cette crise
cette nouvelle intervention militaire en
centrafrique après des années d'une
tutelle française qui ne leur a jamais
permis de trouver le chemin de la
stabilité de la paix et du développement
alors quand sera dépassé l'urgence
d'arrêter les mac les massacres les
vrais question se posera se poseront
notre pays ne va-t-il pas ni va-t-il pas
pour rétablir un minimum d'ordre et
reprendre la main sur le plan économique
et stratégique
tout cela en accord avec l'union
européenne et les etats unis
cette façon de gérer le conflit ne
risque-t-elle pas de perpétuer
l'instabilité la violence et l'échec
bien sûr dans l'immédiat il faut mettre
un terme aux violences qui ensanglantent
le pays la centrafrique ne doit pas
sombrer dans une guerre civile ici ville
intra communautaires mais au-delà de cet
aspect conjoncturel il faut surtout
s'attaquer aux causes profondes qui
déstabilise ce pays depuis si longtemps
il s'agit tout d'abord de casser la
relation néocolonial que nous
entretenons avec lui de la même façon il
est nécessaire que les pays voisins
comme le tchad cesse de considérer la
centrafrique hommes leur arrière-cour il
est grand temps que les centrafricains
recouvre pleinement leur souveraineté il
faudrait ensuite lutter contre la
pauvreté
véritable fléau dans la région cela
passera nécessairement et il faudra bien
en discuter une bonne fois pour toutes
par une remise à plat de la répartition
des dividendes tirés de l'exploitation
par les grands groupes multinationaux
des ressources naturelles
libérer du joug de la domination et de
l'exploitation
les centrafricains seront alors à même
de tourner la page des putschs et des
rebellions le débat que nous avons cet
après midi mais à nouveau fortement en
évidence que dans ce type de crise
internationale il faut avoir une
approche globale et qu'il faut traiter
les causes et pas seulement les
conséquences nous l'avions déjà dit avec
d'autres ici même il y a quelques mois
lors du débat sur le mali le
gouvernement doit sans tarder procéder à
une véritable refonte de l'ensemble de
notre politique des publics au
développement qui redéfinissent ses
objectifs ses enjeux et ses moyens à cet
égard les résultats de la conférence de
paris qui pour l'essentiel se borne à
offrir aux africains notre aide pour
prendre en charge leur propre sécurité
n'est absolument pas à la hauteur des
enjeux vous devriez par des actes
concrets rompre avec la politique de vos
prédécesseurs qui donnait aux pays
africains l'image d'une france dont le
seul souci était de bénéficier de leurs
ressources aux meilleures conditions
al'inverse il faut maintenant nouer de
véritables partenariats équilibrés de
nouvelles relations économiques avec les
états entretenir des relations
débarrassées des arrière pensées de
simple préservation de nos intérêts
économiques et stratégiques vous l'aurez
compris j'ai terminé monsieur le
président notre groupe estime que cette
intervention militaire ne s'inscrit pas
du tout dans ce cadre nous le regrettons
nous en dea pouvons donc la forme et
nous dit-on qu'elle soit la réponse
appropriée à l'acquis à la crise que
traverse la centrafrique merci de votre
attention merci la parole à monsieur
françois rebsamen pour le groupe
socialiste
au
président
merci
monsieur le président monsieur mise la
descente messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
comme d'autres intervenants
en cet instant ma première pensée va aux
deux soldats qui ont trouvé la mort ce
matin en accomplissant leur devoir je
leur rends à mon tour hommage et
j'exprime toute mes condoléances en mon
nom et au nom de mes collègues des
collègues de man group à leur famille à
leurs proches et à leurs camarades de
combat une fois de plus la façon dont
l'armée française accompli sa mission
avec professionnalisme
avec ténacité avec rapidité et
efficacité
fait honneur à notre pays le courage de
nos soldats fait écho à celui de leurs
prédécesseurs qui montaient au front il
y à bientôt un siècle et dont nous
aurons ici même l'occasion d'honorer la
mémoire dans le cadre du centenaire de
la grande guerre mais ce qui me vient à
l'esprit également c'est le nombre
d'enfants de femmes et d'hommes qui
t'ont qui ont été sauvés par l'arrivée
des troupes françaises sur le sol de
centrafrique même si les vies épargnées
ne compense en aucune manière la mort de
nos militaires
aujourd'hui pour autant la normalisation
de la situation est loin d'être acquise
la population sort peu à peu de la
terreur les meurtres les viols les
massacres atroces dans bangui ont cessé
et cela seul à seul suffirait à
justifier si besoin en était
l'intervention française sous mandat de
l'onu face au drame qui se jouait en
centrafrique la france fidèle à sa
tradition de puissance responsable et
fidèle à ses valeurs humanistes a pris
les devants et agit pour que la
communauté internationale
assume son rôle face à un enjeu qui est
tout à la fois
sécuritaire et humanitaire
en effet cela était dit par d'autres
intervenants l'enjeu sécuritaire est
d'importance la situation en
centrafrique s'inscrit dans un cycle qui
remonte dans les années 90 et la crise
actuelle n'est qu'un nul team espérons
le soubresaut d'un spiral de troubles
qui fragilise et détruisent
progressivement la république
centrafricaine depuis 1996 en 1998 déjà
face à l'instabilité croissante et à des
violences exacerbées le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies avait envoyé
une première mission la mission des
nations unies en république
centrafricaine
celle ci avait tenté déjà conjointement
à une force interafricaine de rétablir
la paix et la sécurité dans ce pays lors
de son retrait en 2000 les tensions
persistaient fin 2012 après bien des
péripéties bien des rébellions confortée
par des ingérences étrangères les
troubles latents se sont transformés en
crise majeure là c'est les cas un
regroupement composite finalement
rassemblant tous les déçus du régime du
président si je peux l'appeler président
lui même ayant pris le pouvoir par un
coup d'état du président bozizé
opposants politiques comme arme et s'est
emparé des villes stratégiques
le 11 janvier 2013 de nouveaux accords
de paix sont signés à libreville entre
le gouvernement et la rébellion il
s'agit de mettre un terme à
l'insurrection et de contenir la
rébellion aux portes de bangui
l'instauration d'un gouvernement d'unité
nationale de transition échoue et de
nouvelles élections ne peuvent être
tenues en mars dernier la celica
comptera donc le président en bolivie et
à quitter le pouvoir et michel giotto
dia à se décréter vi qui était vice
premier ministre de la défense du
gouvernement d'union nationale les chefs
des factions rebelles à s'autoproclamer
président du gouvernement de transition
il dissout officiellement la cdca et
lâche ainsi la bride à une soldatesque
d'environ vingt mille hommes cette masse
grossit de jour en jour avec l'arrivée
de nouveaux combattants en provenance de
pays voisins ou les connaissez que ce
soit des combattants soudanais des
éléments qui appartiennent à boko haram
au nigeria et un retour de miliciens ou
l'avait évoqué mon cher collègue de la
lra l'armée de la résistance du seigneur
du tristement célèbre joseph kony qui
détient 1 qui est déjà implanté dans une
partie d'ailleurs notre centrafrique la
république centrafricaine est ainsi en
passe de devenir sur sa totalité une
zone de non droit carrefour stratégique
entre le sahel la région des grands lacs
et la corne de l'afrique c'est donc une
crise qui a des répercussions régionales
important puisque la plupart des états
voisins font le même face à des défis
sécuritaires considérable
les frontières sont poreuses les foyers
de tension énorme et nous ne pouvons pas
laisser la république centrafricaine
devenir une source de déstabilisation
supplémentaires voire une base arrière
pour le développement d'activités
terroristes
l'enjeu sécuritaire l'enjeu sécuritaire
se double en effet d'un enjeu
humanitaire immense cela était dit bien
sûr mais je voudrais le rappeler sans
qu'il faille actuellement employés de
grands mots parler de génocide
le pays fait face à un tel climat de
violence que saleh laissait présager une
évolution vers un conflit à connotation
confessionnelles
là c'est les cas est majoritairement
composé vous le savez de musulmans
tandis qu'une majorité de la population
de mouvance chrétienne on l'a vu hélas
images télévisuelles l'ont attesté la
violence se déchaîne et est allé
croissant les violences de droits de
l'homme ont été quotidienne ne cessant
de s'amplifier les civils ont été la
cible de multiples exactions
arrestations et détentions arbitraires
exécutions sommaires
violations violences sexuelles tortures
pillages
enrôlement d'enfants soldats drogués les
femmes et les enfants étant
particulièrement visée on dénombre
aujourd'hui environ un million trois
cent mille personnes victimes d'un super
hit et alimentaires soit un tiers de la
population
ainsi que 480 mille déplacés dont
cinquante mille à bangui le haut
commissariat des nations unies a
enregistré depuis le d affrontement 66
mille réfugiés
malheureusement les ong ne peuvent pas
apporter des aides aux populations qui
sont dans le besoin face à ce danger de
catastrophe humanitaire
face à ce danger de catastrophe
humanitaire c'était un devoir impératif
que de mettre un terme à ce cycle
infernal
je citerai ici le président de la
république lors du sommet africain à
l'elysée aujourd'hui 10 est il au coeur
de l'afrique un peuple est en souffrance
il nous appelle nous ne pouvons plus
laisser les massacres se perpétrer cet
engagement n'est pas simplement
sécuritaire il doit être humanitaire
parce que c'est aussi notre devoir comme
lors de la crise malienne je le dit le
président de la république a su prendre
la mesure de la gravité de la situation
et je veux ici le souligner et lui
rendre hommage dès le 24 septembre
dernier dans son discours à la sueur 68e
assemblée générale des nations unies le
président de la république avait lancé
un cri d'alarmé sur la situation en
république centrafricaine il avait alors
invité la communauté internationale à se
mobiliser et à agir sous l'égide du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
pendant de longs mois la france a
réitéré cette volonté et à travailler à
la résolution de la crise elle a fait
adopter une première résolution par le
conseil de sécurité d'ores et déjà celle
ci définit le cadre politique de
l'intervention actuelle en autorisant la
france à aider nos partenaires africains
mobilisées sur le terrain depuis de
nombreuses années elle autorise
également notre pays à accompagner la
montée en puissance d'une force
internationale dont le mandat a été
présentement fixés par la résolution
21-27 voté il ya quelques jours
l'intervention sans garris diffère de la
situation de l'opération serval qui a
été mené au mali la situation de ce pays
n'est pas celle que les troupes
françaises en trouver au mali en début
d'année la république centrafricaine est
aujourd'hui à n'en pas douter un état
failli les groupes rebelles s'affrontent
et les exactions y sont systématiques
les forces de sécurité ne dispose ni des
moyens techniques ni des ressources
humaines suffisantes à l'exercice de
leurs fonctions il s'agit donc dans une
situation de chaos de poser les jalons
d'une intervention internationale qui
devra embrasser l'ensemble des défis qui
s'imposent
l'action qui doit être menée et qui sera
mené avec nos partenaires recouvre en
effet quatre domaines la sécurité
je les dis la dimension humanitaire oui
nous le savons la transition politique
indispensable et ensuite le
développement économique c'est donc à
une mission
multidimensionnelle que la france et la
communauté internationale vont devoir
s'atteler je le dis ici
la france n'est pas seule elle bénéficie
du soutien de tous les membres du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies et
la france est aux côtés des africains
regroupés au sein de la muscat sans cela
la sécurisation ne serait pas durable
l'opération qui est menée interviendra
bien sûr a été fait avec des
préparations sur le plan militaire
logistique et financier la crise
centrafricaine sera d'ailleurs à l'ordre
du jour du conseil européen du 19
décembre date à laquelle débutera la
mission des nations unies l'union
européenne cela a été rappelé apporte
certes un premier soutien financier et
lacq orthez dz en 2013 à hauteur de 20
millions d'euros la commission
européenne a débloqué la semaine
dernière 50 millions d'euros sans
compter une aide matérielle mais à cet
égard je considère que les dépenses
liées à des interventions extérieures de
notre pays au service de la paix au
service de la lutte contre le terrorisme
et au secours des populations en danger
doivent être absolument sortie du calcul
du déficit budgétaire de notre pays la
france
la france ne peut agir au nom des autres
nations notamment européennes en faveur
de l'intérêt international et en être en
même temps pénalisé le citoyen français
ne le comprendraient pas et je le dis
ils auraient raison je souhaite donc
monsieur le ministre que le gouvernement
que vous agissiez avec le gouvernement
dans ce sens au niveau européen dès le
sommet de la semaine prochaine
comme pour l'opération serval
l'opération qui se déroule actuellement
participe de notre volonté de consolider
notre partenariat avec nos amis
africains pour la paix et la sécurité
sur le continent qui ne peut être
confortée et qui ne peut que conforter
il faut le rappeler ici celle de
l'europe il est bien clair que
l'ambition de la france n'est pas de
rester durablement en centrafrique en
centrafrique mais de faciliter et de
soutenir la communauté internationale et
nos partenaires africains dans leurs
actions en matière de sécurité
collective la france oui je le pense est
fidèle à sa mission elle agit en soutien
des africains conformément à la légalité
internationale et elle travaille pour ap
notre participation n'est donc le
premier jalon qui doit conduire nos
partenaires nos partenaires africains à
assumer leur propre sécurité c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sens des propositions
qui ont été débattus lors du sommet de
l'elysée avec la recherche de la mise en
place d'une force de réaction rapide
africaine qui pourrait jouer un rôle
semblable à celui tenu par la france au
mali et en république centrafricaine
cette volonté a été unanimement saluée
lors du sommet de l'elysée par les chefs
d'état de tout le continent africain et
par le secrétaire général des nations
unies ban ki moon comme le disait le
président de la république devant ses
homologues c'est la responsabilité des
africains de maîtriser aujourd'hui en
sécurité mais la france dans sa mission
est prête à apporter son concours elle
est prête à former à équiper et apporter
du renseignement bien sûr aux armées
africaines si nécessaire à l'heure où la
tentation du repli sur soi se généralise
la france et l'ensemble des formations
quasiment unanime quasiment quasiment la
france a dû dépasser et a su dépasser
ses préoccupations nationales pour se
porter au secours d'un peuple en
souffrance en cela je le crois notre
pays se montre fidèle et digne de sa
vocation de patrie des droits de l'homme
mesdames messieurs chers collègues je
vous invite tous collectivement en être
fier merci
merci
merci je passe la parole à présent à
jean michel baylet pour le groupe
rds
monsieur le président monsieur mini mes
chers collègues je souhaite bien sûr en
prélude en intervention rendre hommage à
mon tour de soldats du 8ème 8e rpima de
castres nicolas rocard est en taule à
tignes aux morts hier soir mendy souris
sous l'uniforme de l'armée française et
je salue leur courage et leur engagement
et chers collègues le vote de la
résolution mai 2007 à l'onu puis
l'engagement nos troupes en soutien de
leurs homologues d'afrique centrale sont
intervenues alors que se tenait le
sommet franco africaine de l'elysée
consacrée à la paix et à la sécurité
il entrera en application de l'article
35 constitution survient juste en les à
l'examen en seconde lecture par notre
assemblée de la loi de programmation
militaire et alors que se tiendra demain
soir ici même un débat préalable au
conseil européen des 19 et 20 décembre
consacré justement à la politique de
sécurité et de défense commune
chers collègues
l'adoption à l'unanimité de cette
résolution vient couronner il faut le
dire un patient travail de notre
diplomatie afin de convaincre les autres
pays membres du conseil de sécurité de
la nécessité absolue
d'accorder mandat clair l'intervention
sous chapitre 7 à la mission
internationale de soutien à la
république centrafricaine sous conduite
africaine à la miss k et aux forces
françaises en effet nous le savons la
situation au nord de l'oubangui est
passé disons d'inquiétantes à critique
puis
dramatique docker en arrière un peu
rapidement ou pas facilité rapprocher le
cas centrafricain du scénario malienne
si l'on peut concéder c'est vrai
quelques similitudes et fondements de
l'état tensions religieuses
tensions régionales nombreuses sont
aussi les dissemblances
l'instabilité chronique presse
consubstantiel de la république
centrafricaine et la faiblesse pour ne
pas dire l'inexistence de l'état sont
avérés ils face à ce long délitement qui
s'est accentuée très fortement depuis
une douzaine d'années les pays de la
région sont intervenus dans le cadre de
la formule puis de la micopax et ils ont
d'être soutenu naturellement j'ai envie
de dire par la présence française dans
l'opération boali se borner à la
sécurisation des ressortissants français
et des points d'intérêt stratégique
mais le coup de force le coup d'état de
la série k le 24 mars dernier a entraîné
l'éclatement des accords de libreville
l'exil du président bozizé et la prise
de pouvoir par les rebelles cet
événement bien sûr comme à chaque fois
en pareil cas exacerber les tensions
régionales
les tensions confessionnelles dans des
proportions tragiques en effet face aux
composantes de la série k
principalement issus du nord du pays
majoritairement musulman et nous
trouvons là un schéma auquel nous sommes
malheureusement habitués dans beaucoup
d'états africaine des milices
d'autodéfense dit antibalas cas se sont
constitués esquisse un scénario de
guerre civile et son cortège de
massacres d'horreur et de populations
déplacées une intervention rapide afin
de mettre fin au cycle de la violence et
de la cruauté et est devenu
indispensable et les fondements de
l'état centrafricain que je viens
d'évoquer les c'est également craindre
que ce territoire ne devienne une base
de repli pour certains groupes armés ils
sont nombreux dans la zone de pays
voisins soudan tchad république
démocratique du congo au nigeria et donc
entraîne une nouvelle source
d'instabilité pour l'ensemble de la
région alors mes chers collègues j'ai
entendu certains responsables politiques
sert mine de s'interroger sur les
objectifs et la stratégie du
gouvernement
pourtant le mandat donné par la
résolution est de mise c'est à la miss k
et aux forces françaises et d'une grande
clarté
illégitime is bianca dans cette
intervention et cette opération comporte
même un volet sécuritaire mais aussi un
volet humanitaire et prévoit
l'accompagnement du pays dans le
rétablissement de ces institutions et
notamment du processus électoral elle
était nous l'avons vu et nous en avons
tous des informations de ce ministre
surtout très attendus comme l'indiquent
l'accueil remarquable des populations de
bangui à l'arrivée de nos troupes et le
fait d'ailleurs que de nombreux
habitants se soit réfugié autour de
l'aéroport de la ville où sont
stationnés les éléments de l'opération
100 garris salissant de la durée de cet
engagement cette résolution accords
demandant de 12 mois mais bien sûr qu'il
est souhaitable que les unités
combattantes françaises les se place le
plus tôt possible à une force de
maintien de la paix cependant des
questions demeurent notamment autour du
programme ddr désarmement démobilisation
et réintégration de la série k qui
demeure une zone de grand flou et
d'incertitudes il est taclé renens effet
un repli de ses forces dans la partie
septentrionale du pays voire dans les
pays limitrophes et la question de la
place du président defacto et chef de la
série k michel georges aura dans la
transition doit être aussi posée selon
les accords de libreville ce dernier ne
pourra se présenter lors des futures
élections et le prêt la république
française françois hollande s'est
exprimé sur le sujet alors mes chers
collègues le voulons la france et son
rôle moteur dans diplomatiquement aux
nations-unies que sur le terrain avec le
déploiement rapide de nos forces mérite
d'être souligné lerhe configuration
géopolitique notamment le
repositionnement des etats-unis vers
l'arc asie-pacifique mettre l'entreprise
en première ligne dans la résolution des
crises africaines en conséquence comme
le préconise et déjà le livre blanc les
priorités la france ont été resserrés
autour du maghreb et de la méditerranée
orientale et de l'afrique notamment le
sahel nous prenons de nous féliciter que
le gouvernement ait réaffirmé notamment
dans la loire opérations militaires sa
volonté de conserver ses bases
prépositionnés à djibouti au sénégal au
gabon auquel s'ajoutent les bases
stationné à nos premières je rappelle
que les fermetures étaient engagés par
la précédente majorité et c'est pour ça
monsieur le ministre vous avez bien fait
de revenir là dessus ce maillage qui a
permis le déploiement avec une rapidité
remarquable est digne d'être soulignée
de nos forces à bannir car mes chers
collègues cette relation particulière de
la france à l'afrique se manifeste aussi
lors du récent sommet de paris qui a
réuni chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
l'ensemble du continent la disparition
nelson mandela alors que s'ouvre ce
sommet est venue nous rappeler que les
valeurs de dévouement et d'humilité de
ce grand homme
constitue un exemple pour les dirigeants
d'afrique et du monde et françois
hollande l'a annoncé lors de son
intervention je le cite sans sécurité
pas de développement sans développement
pas de sécurité la doctrine du prêt à la
banque française en matière de politique
africaine s'affirme de jour en jour elle
repose sur un règlement multilatéral des
conflits avec les nations unies mais
aussi sur l'appli implication des
organisations régionales ici la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique centrale
et continental l'union africaine la
phrase c'est mes chers collègues assume
donc les responsabilités qui lui
incombent que cela plaise ou pas du fait
de son statut de puissance et aussi nous
devons l'assumer de son héritage
historique et ce sont de véritables
partenariats qui se met en place et là
encore nous sommes vraiment d'époque
dans la déclaration finale du sommet de
l'elysée les dirigeants français et
africains souhaité la création d'une
force africaine de résolution des crises
d l'horizon 2015 la foi devrait même
participer à la formation de cette force
même s'il est question suscite
naturellement monsieur le ministre sur
son financement elle permettrait en tout
cas d'afrique est d'assurer la sécurité
de leur continent
chers collègues je salue ici
la volée de triples la république et du
gouvernement d'informer d'associer les
prix dans des assemblées les présents
des groupes politiques et des
commissions des affaires étrangères et
de la défense du sénat et de l'assemblée
et notre débat doit nous permettre
également de lever les dernières
interrogations nées de notre
intervention en république
centrafricaine la première concerne
capacités de production dans le cas de
la lamproie sur militaire les opérations
de gestion de crise pour être menée sur
deux ou trois théâtres d'intervention
est content et je crois monsieur mini 6
à 7000 hommes le prêt à la république
avait annoncé que 16 cents militaires
seraient mobilisés en république
centrafricaine ils s'ajoutent aux 2800
présent au mali nous nous approchons
c'est vrai de la limite de nos capacités
d'invention mais souligne sommes quand
même que nos armées peuvent aussi
compter sur les 15 millions du format
opération majeure de coercition en
coalition ou sur les forces et mais
également sur les forces prépositionnées
une autre intérieur majeure a été levée
à cette tribune concerne l'union
européenne qui reste comme d'habitude
serait on tenté de dire en retrait même
si la commission européenne
annoncé la mise en place d'un pont
aérien humanitaire entre douala et benji
nous paie à la république a déclaré le
prochain conseil européen des 25 sera le
moment cependant la création d'un fonds
pour financer ce genre d'opération de
résolution de crise monsieur le ministre
peut être pourrez vous nous confirmez en
fait il se pose la question du processus
de construction de la paix et de la
reconstruction problème de la
construction d'un état et d'institutions
démocratiques en centrafrique cela
passera comme au mali par une nécessaire
indispensable réconciliation alors ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui en république
centrafricaine ce dernier - monsieur
linh mes chers collègues que la sécurité
et l'avenir non seulement d'une région
mais également d'un continent
l'engagement de nos troupes et de
lamiscarre doit permettre aux
centrafricains de redevenir maîtres de
leur destin et pour les raisons que j'ai
exposé cette intervention est conforme
au droit international est conforme à
notre constitution
elle est légitime elle est nécessaire le
préau de la république a bien fait de la
décider et bien naturellement les
sénateurs radicaux de gauche et lance sa
venue à dire ceux vous apporte un
soutien franc et massif
merci je passe la parole à notre
collègue kalliopi ango ela pour le
groupe écologiste
je
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense mesdames et
monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense des forcenés
mes chers collègues nous sommes
aujourd'hui réunis en application de
l'article 35 alinéa 2 de la constitution
je tiens si vous me le permettez à titre
liminaire a rappelé la position des
écologistes qui aspire concernant cette
intervention en centrafrique et d'une
façon générale s'agissant des
interventions de nos forces à l'étranger
a rappelé à ce que nos débats puissent
être suivi d'un vote de nos deux
assemblées en l'espèce le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu a autorisé jeudi le
déploiement de la mission internationale
de soutien à la centrafrique sous
conduite africaine muscat pour une
période de 12 mois en adoptant à
l'unanimité de ses 15 membres la
résolution 21 27 le conseil a confié un
mandat en plusieurs volets à cette
mission
appuyée par des forces françaises
autorisé à je cite prendre
temporairement toute mesure nécessaire
la musca est notamment chargé de
contribuer à protéger les civils et
rétablir la sécurité et l'ordre publics
à stabiliser le pays et à créer les
conditions propices à la fourniture
d'une aide humanitaire au pop in aux
populations qui en ont besoin avant de
revenir plus en détail sur les diverses
dispositions de cette résolution
onusienne et sur la place centrale qui
doit être donnée aux forces africaines
dans cette opération il me semble
important de rappeler le drame que qui
se vide depuis déjà trop longtemps en
république centrafricaine depuis la
prise de bangui au printemps dernier par
lasser les cas la rca et le théâtre de
pillages d'exactions de violences
atroces à l'égard de la population
civile la situation dramatique qui
touche le pays s'est aggravée ces
dernières semaines plongeant la
centrafrique dans des violences
meurtrières ayant entraîné près de 400
morts jeudi et vendredi à bangui la
croix rouge centrafricaine ramasser jour
samedi des dizaines de cadavres
abandonnés depuis les violents
affrontements des jours précédents
précédent suivie de tuerie à l'armé à
feu ou à la match est des centaines de
blessés est également content il
comptabilisé par médecins sans
frontières les vivres des violences
sexuelles faites aux femmes se sont
aussi multipliées tandis que des enfants
ont été enrôlés comme soldats depuis
plusieurs semaines face à cette
situation inacceptable
il était urgent de réagir les
écologistes tiennent ici à réaffirmer
que la capacité des pays d'afrique à
assurer eux-mêmes leur circulent leur
sécurité est un objectif qui requiert le
soutien international et
particulièrement européens si nous
saluons le soutien logistique annoncé
par plusieurs étals européens au profit
de la musique à l annonce de 50 millions
d'euros à l'union de l'union européenne
à la demande de l'union africaine
toujours au profit de la miss k nous
regrettons que la françois nouveau seul
à intervenir dans le cadre du soutien à
cette opération
l'urgence humanitaire et sécuritaire
requiert à soutien collectif de nos
partenaires européens afin de protéger
la population centrafricaine
rétablir la sécurité et la stabilité du
pays au delà et c'est l'essentiel selon
moi cette opération en centrafrique doit
reposer sur l'engagement des forces
africaines et de leur nécessaire
implication un sel ainsi que de celle de
l'union africaine
je salue à ce sujet le fait que lors des
travaux du sommet de l'elysée pour la
paix et la sécurité en afrique les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement et appelé à
une réforme du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies permettant de renforcer la
place de l'afrique dans le cadre d'un
conseil élargi avec je me réjouis
également des avancées importantes
réalisées par l'union africaine les
communautés économiques régionales et
les états africains dans la mise en
oeuvre d'opérations de paix comme au
mali en république centrafricaine en
somalie en guinée bissau au burundi au
soudan par q les au darfour aucun mort
ces initiatives apporte des solutions
africaines aux problèmes africains et
doivent être soutenus par la communauté
internationale je citais les sénatrices
et sénateurs écologistes réaffirme
beaucoup si l'importance de développer
les capacités africaines de réaction aux
crises et salue l'engagement de la
france lors de ce sommet à soutenir les
efforts de l'union africaine pour
parvenir à une pleine capacité
opérationnelle de la force africaine en
attente et de sa capacité de déploiement
rapide à l'horizon 2015 ainsi que la
capacité africaine de réponse immédiate
aux crises carrick tel que décidé par le
sommet de l'union africaine en mai 2013
par ailleurs il me semble important de
rappeler que par la résolution 21 27 le
conseil de sécurité prie le secrétaire
général de l'onu de créer un fonds
d'affectation spéciale auxquelles les
membres et organisations internationales
régionales et sous régionales pourront
verser des contributions financières à
la mission la résolution lui demande
également de créer rapidement une
commission d' enquête internationale
pour une période initiale
d'un an
pour une période initiale d'un an
chargée d'enquêter sur les violations du
droit international international
humanitaire et du droit international
des droits de l'homme qui auraient été
perpétrés en centrafrique par quelque
parti que ce soit depuis le 1er janvier
2013 les signalements de violences y
compris de violences
interconfessionnelles ou
intercommunautaires n'ayant cessé de se
multiplier au cours de l'année écoulée
je soulignerai enfin que la résolution
instaure aussi pour une période initiale
d'un an un embargo pour empêcher la
fourniture la vente ou le transfert en
rca d'armements et de matériel connexe
de tous types un comité des sanctions
sera chargée en particulier de veiller
au respect par tous les états membres
dudit embargo les écologistes seront
particulièrement attentifs à ces deux
derniers points cet engagement des
forces françaises en centrafrique en
soutien la miss cap sous mandat de l'onu
et à la demande du goût finalement
centrafricain de la société civile de
hershey a et des états voisins et donc
une étape nécessaire en vue d'éviter une
catastrophe humanitaire cependant nous
devons tous et toutes prendre la pleine
mesure de la complexité de la situation
géopolitique en république
centrafricaine le mauvais état des
routes et des pistes la diversité des
groupes armés rejoints par des brigands
bandits de grand chemin et groupuscules
crapules sur fond de conflits
interreligieux rendre extrêmement
compliqué la tâche de la muscade de nos
forces armées il est dès lors difficile
de déterminer de façon précise et qui
agit d'autant que nous sommes face à
plusieurs groupes armés évanescent qui
risquent de se reconstituer aussi vite
qu'ils seront dissous il s'agit donc de
ne pas tomber dans l'écueil d'une vision
binaire c'est lé cas contre antibalas
cas où musulmans contre chrétiens la
housse la situation est beaucoup plus
complexe noto co2 nombreux
centrafricains d'obédience musulmane
se désolidarise clairement de la celica
déjà fort morcelé et ne souhaite pas du
tout y être assimilée dans ce contexte
il nous appartient donc de faire preuve
de précaution a fortiori en raison de la
perméabilité des frontières avec les
états voisins les enjeux 0
géostratégique sont donc de taille au
risque que la rca devienne une base
arrière de groupes plus radicaux
déstabilisant ou infiltrant l'ensemble
de la région d'afrique centrale si les
grandes villes pourront à terme être
mieux sécurisés ainsi que les grands
axes en particulier lax bangui douala
l'instauration d'une paix et d'une
sécurité durable risque d'être plus
délicate à partir à obtenir et à
consolider à partir du moment où le pays
est très difficile d'accès dans mon dans
des
superficies très importante je salue
d'ailleurs le courage et l'engagement
des soldats de la miss carey des troupes
françaises notre groupe tient également
à rendre un profond hommage aux deux
militaires français du 8e régiment de
parachutistes d'infanterie de marine de
castres tués cette nuit en opérer en
opération à bangui cette intervention
s'annonce donc malheureusement longue et
difficile s'il dangereuse et d'une
complexité sans précédent c'est comme
concernant l'intervention au mali la
phase militaire devra laisser au plus
vite la place à la phase politique puis
au temps du développement la différence
résulte dans le contexte particulier de
la centrafrique au fait que l'état soit
particulièrement affaiblie voire
peu existants
la reconstruction de l'état
centrafricain dans ce contexte de est
affaiblie depuis de nombreuses années
sera le préalable nécessaire à sa
stabilité et à l'organisation
d'élections démocratiques dans un pays
où les archives administratives et
l'état civil ont été détruits une fois
la paix rétablie ce que nous appelons
évidemment de tous nos voeux et
rapidement
quid de la constitution de ses listes
électorales ce n'est pas un processus
simple les difficultés seront donc
multiples et nous devons d'ores et déjà
les envisager enfin nous ne pouvons
évidemment pas évoqué l'objectif ne pas
évoquer l'objectif de paix de sécurité
en centrafrique sans aborder l'ultime
est nécessaire étapes de développement
de lutte contre la pauvreté qui a
d'ailleurs été intégré au sommet de
l'elysée à l'initiative en particulier
du ministre des affaires étrangères et
du ministre délégué pascal canfin cette
étape de reconstitution social et
économique passera par l'aide au
développement qui nécessitera une
mobilisation de tous les acteurs il
s'agira de mettre tout en oeuvre avec
les autres états européens l'union
européenne et l'ensemble de la société
internationale pour parvenir à un
système de partenariat et de
développement associant le futur état
centrafricain reconstruit conflit dès la
société civile les organisations
régionales africaines les états
africains et les ong en tant que
sénatrice représentant les français
établis hors de france je pense bien
évidemment aussi aux français établis en
centrafrique dont certains ont dû
rentrer en au printemps dernier certains
sont restés ou d'autres se sont
réinstallés dans d'autres pays d'afrique
la dimension militaire ne suffira
évidemment pas résoudre tous ces
problèmes d'un pays extrêmement pauvre
je conclurai en citant vassilis alexakis
qui est un équivalent amoureux de bangui
est d'origine franco grecque qui dans
son ouvrage intitulé éléments étrangers
disait en en quête d'une langue inconnue
le sango pour lui et c'est justement ce
qui l'intéressait d'apprendre à travers
cet apprentissage d'une langue rare avec
laquelle ils n'avaient pas de lien lors
l'auteur décide d'un voyage à bangui est
il écrit la mort aussi se lèvent de
bonne heure à ben 10 j'ai mis du temps à
me remettre de cette révélation
j'ajouterai que depuis le 24 mars
dernier elle ne cesse malheureusement de
se lever de bonne heure pour les
centrafricains afin que cela cesse au
plus vite le groupe écologiste
soutiendra l'engagement des forces
armées en république centrafricaine je
vous remercie
merci je passe la parole à jean louis
carrère président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense
mesdames les ministres
mes chers collègues
comme l'ensemble des intervenants je
veux rendre hommage à nos deux soldats
du 8e rpima de castres tué hier soir en
république centrafricaine
et présenter nos condoléances à leurs
familles et à leurs camarades
c'est mort pour la france mes chers
collègues pour la paix et la sécurité
internationales viennent nous rappeler
la négation nécessaires au métier
militaire
puisqu'il implique l'acceptation du
sacrifice de sa vie
nous exprimons ici notre peine profonde
et notre solidarité sans faille avec nos
troupes
comment mali en 2012 notre pays se
trouve en pointe en république
centrafricaine devant la dégradation
insupportable de la situation
humanitaire
l'alertent a été donnée par le président
de la république lors de son discours
devant l'assemblée générale de l'onu dès
le 24 septembre dernier il a fallu deux
résolutions du conseil de sécurité et
deux mois et demi de négociations
pendant lesquelles les massacres se sont
perpétrés et la dimension
confessionnelle des affrontements a
quelquefois pris le dessus
l'adoption rapide de la résolution jeudi
vers ni ne doit pas nous faire oublier
les difficultés
de sa négociation
celle ci me permettent d'ailleurs une
nouvelle fois de saluer l'extrême
compétence de notre diplomatie qui a su
rassembler et convaincre
ce sont à présent nos soldats qui sont
sur le terrain et nous leur disons toute
la confiance et l'estimé de notre
commission et du sénat monsieur le
président tout entier pour leur
dévouement et l'extraordinaire
professionnalisme dont ils font preuve
dans des conditions et en milieu
particulièrement difficile ma première
remarque porte sur la notion de
responsabilité de protéger qui et c'est
le premier chef des dirigeants et en cas
de défaillance de la communauté
internationale tout entière au travers
de l'onu de son conseil de sécurité
puisque hors cas de légitime défense
c'est l'organisation qui a seul la
légitimité de l'emploi de la coercition
sous chapitre 7 de la charte
certaines y oppose le principe de
souveraineté des états qui d'ailleurs
est le fondement même de l'onu je le
vois quand à moi aucune contradiction
entre ces deux notions du reste
l'utilisation de la force n'est que le
stade ultime de la démarche
d'application du principe de
responsabilité de protéger mais la
souveraineté mes chers collègues ne peut
justifier qu'un gouvernement massacre sa
population ou qu'ils laissent se
perpétrer des massacres
car l'état lui-même disparaît ceux qui
prétendent que c'est au peuple de
choisir leurs dirigeants et de les
renvoyer le cas échéant ferait bien
parfois de réfléchir aux exemples
récents dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
outre l'urgence humanitaire qui
justifierait pour ma part à elle seule
notre action et qui est l'honneur de la
france en république centrafricaine
comme elle le fut en libye
quelles sont nos motivations pour
intervenir j'en vois trois la première
est que nous ne voulons pas laisser la
situation dégénérer avec un état qui n'a
plus d'état que le nom et qui par
contagion entraînerait une situation
extrêmement difficile et dangereuse dans
l'ensemble de la région
si elles se poursuivent et cette
déstabilisation de la centrafrique
serait de nature à compromettre la paix
et la sécurité dans toute la région
d'avoir des conséquences extrêmement
importantes sur les perspectives de
développement de toute la zone et même
du continent cette zone de non-droit
attirerait à coup sûr
un certain nombre de groupes terroristes
et criminelles dont elle deviendrait ou
pourrait devenir le sanctuaire mes chers
collègues après l'afghanistan la somalie
le yémen et le mali cela aurait pu être
le cas de la république centraficaine
les bandes armées de toute nature qu'ils
conviennent de désarmer ce qui est une
tâche extrêmement délicate urgente est
immense par le désordre et l'insécurité
qu'elle entretienne permettent de
masquer la présence d'éléments
terroristes comme ceux de boko haram ou
de la lra l'armée de résistance du
seigneur évoquée par le président
récemment précédemment ces éléments
terroristes sont des menaces directes
contre les intérêts de l'europe et du
monde dans une autre zone on le voit
aussi dans les conséquences de la
progression de la piraterie dans le
golfe de guinée dont l'actualité demande
à être éradiqué sujet que nous
étudierons en commission au cours de
l'année 2014 j'ajoute que la dérive en
conflit confessionnel doit
impérativement être évité et enrayer
c'est la troisième raison de
l'intervention de la communauté
internationale
le rapport présenté le 18 décembre par
le secrétaire général mettait en exergue
le niveau alarmant de violences
intercommunautaires et les affrontements
confessionnels entre chrétiens et
musulmans
il soulignait le risque que les
affrontements dégénèrent en conflits
religieux et ethniques à l'échelle du
pays avec le risque d'aboutir à une
spirale incontrôlable
débouchant sur des atrocités
l'adoption des résolutions 21 21 et 21
27 montre que l'identification de ces
menaces
déstabilisation régionale risque de
création d'un foyer de tous les trafics
dérivant conflits religieux a été
partagée par la communauté
internationale je me félicite en
particulier du soutien unanime des
africains eux mêmes et de leurs
organisations régionales en tout premier
lieu de l'union africaine soutient
qu'ils devaient être relevé par ceux qui
comme de nouveaux cas brille ajoute eux
le souvenir de la françafrique que ce
soit dans le débat politique intérieure
ou chez certaines de nos meilleurs
alliés
la doctrine fixé par le président de la
république est claire pardon de le
rappeler pas d'ingérence politique
action à la demande et aux côtés des
africains et non en substitution
c'est une différence fondamentale de la
centrafrique l'une les conclusions du
sommet de réviser a été de souligner
l'importance de développer les capacités
africaines de réaction aux crises afin
que le continent prennent en charge dès
que possible sa propre sécurité la
france je cite s'est engagé à soutenir
les efforts de l'union africaine pour
parvenir à une pleine capacité
opérationnelle de sa force en attente et
de sa capacité de déploiement rapide à
l'horizon 2015 et ainsi que de sa
capacité de réponse immédiate aux crises
telles que décidées par le sommet de
l'union africaine en mai 2013 cet apport
de notre pays me permet d'aborder le
second point de mon intervention
juste après la clôture de longs débats
nous allons mes chers collègues examiné
en deuxième lecture la loi de
programmation militaire
et comme je suis un esprit à peu près
cohérent tout au moins celle estime et
je vous demanderai votre avis
ultérieurement
nous avons pu consacrer constaté un
consensus quasi unanime de notre
assemblée pour soutenir le gouvernement
et nos forces armées engagées en
république centrafricaine je vous fais
observer qu'il y ait une contradiction
qu'il y aurait une contradiction
certaine entre cette prise de position
qui m'agrée et que je soutiens et on
vote contre les crédits de la loi de
programmation militaire qui nous confère
les moyennes de notre action
nous voyons bien mes chers collègues que
sur les questions de sécurité et de
politique étrangère les forces
politiques savent se rassembler car
c'est l'intérêt national qui est en jeu
puisque en luttant contre les menaces
que nous avons clairement identifiés
c'est la sécurité de notre pays et de
nos concitoyens que nous défendons en
particulier je ne comprends pas comment
on peut affirmer qu'il n'ya pas de
développement sans sécurité
pas plus qu'il n'y a de sécurité sans
développement tout en refusant de se
doter des moyens nécessaires à la
réalisation de cet objectif que je
partage
pour autant les discussions à l'onu
ou au sein de l'union européenne pose
monsieur le ministre
concrètement la question des limites de
notre politique d'intervention en
république centrafricaine comme au mali
ou en côte d'ivoire peut être de même
dans un autre pays le surcoût des opex
en 2013 constaté en loi de finances
rectificative est tout de même de 1,26
milliard d'euros à comparer aux 630
millions budgétés en loi de finances
initiale 2013 et aux 450 millions
provisionnés pour 2014
certes le financement mes chers
collègues grâce à vous et couvert par la
réserve interministériel et nous y avons
veillé en loi de programmation militaire
il ne pèsera donc pas directement sur le
budget du ministère de la défense mais
nous voyons bière la limite de la
multiplication des interventions alors
même que nous avons beaucoup de mal à
seulement stabiliser les crédits en
euros constants ces interventions qui
sont pleinement justifiées et la france
doit assumer ses responsabilités deux
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
mais il est évident que nous ne pouvons
supporter seul le poids tant militaires
que financier de ses interventions à
vitam aeternam le relais des
organisations régionales et de l'onu
comme de l'union européenne sur ces deux
plans est indispensable il faut mettre
nos partenaires européens de voir leur
responsabilité
si les menaces de déstabilisation en
afrique concerne directement l'europe
alors il faut en tirer les conséquences
autrement qu'en paroles ou camp
politique du carnet de chèques la france
participe déjà par son aide bilatérale
que ce soit en matière d' aide au
développement ou de formation à cela
s'ajoutera la quote-part de notre pays à
l'appui financier de l'union en plus
nous devrions supporter seules le
fardeau de l'intervention militaire si
je veux féliciter des soutiens apportés
par certaines de nos alliés mes chers
collègues je note avec un o fils silence
assourdissant
d'autres partenaires et non des moindres
l'inutilisation et donc peut-être
l'italie telle inutilité des battle
group est flagrante
nous ne pouvons être durablement les
seuls à prendre nos responsabilités
toutes ces questions vous l'avez compris
monsieur le ministre devant être
clairement posée lors du conseil
européen des 19 et 20 décembre mais
c'est demain soir que nous vous dirons
ce que nous souhaitons que vous puissiez
porté à ce sommet européen dont nous
attendons beaucoup je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole et
a jailli le drian ministre de la défense
voilà pour ce débat consacré à
l'intervention militaire de la france